ce mardi les enfants de montigny le
bretonneux partent à la chasse aux
détritus l'école paul-fort a organisé
cette activité afin de sensibiliser ses
élèves au ramassage des déchets notre
école dans son projet de développement
durable est très attaché au à la notion
de biodiversité
donc on a un jardin une serre et au
travail dans la nature en permanence et
donc la nature il faut la protéger
ramasser des déchets en fait partie
équipés de gants de sacs et de pinces
aucun détritus n'a pu résister face aux
parents et à cette jeunesse motivée
très belle harnachement déjà de l'école
de participer à ce genre d'action est
chez vu des enfants très motivés à
ramasser les petites échelles
j'étais bien qu'ils me ramasser des
déchets
lan déchets ménagers déchets qui coupent
est-ce que la bière fait d'éviter les
plastiques dans cette poubelle
accompagnés par l'association je
respecte ma ville les enfants ont pu
découvrir le fonctionnement du tri
sélectif c'est à lui qu'appartient le
world et dès demain nous on est juste la
génération qui prend conscience et les
élèves et les plus jeunes c'est alors
qu'on est seulement de demandes et
besoins cet événement organisé afin de
toucher le plus d'enfants et de parents
annoncent le lancement de la nouvelle
saison du world food day qui se
déroulera le 10 septembre
[Musique]